[Musique]
68 jours d'élections présidentielles
notre rendez vous désormais tous les
lundis avec vous achetez de verdure en
avant de retrouver chaque jour à partir
du 14 mars bonsoir raphaël bonsoir à
vous tous cette semaine le thème du
pouvoir d'achat s'est invitée dans la
campagne salaires prix de l'énergie les
candidats été bien inspiré de son saisir
car selon les sondages c'est le thème
qui comptera le plus pour les électeurs
dans le choix qu'ils feront en avril
prochain un thème de prédilection pour
la gauche qui n'affiche toujours pas de
front uni même si elle affirme qu'elle
appellera à nianing fabien et jean-luc
christiane taubira victorieuse de la
primaire populaire ne parvient pas à
rassembler les autres candidats de
gauche derrière sa candidature le récap
politique est signée florent roudaut et
autriche et
c'est l'histoire d'un lointain rêve
nommé union de la gauche
christiane taubira gagne le match de la
primaire populaire et se verrait bien en
capitaine d'équipé
nous voulons une gauche unie nous
voulons une gauche de boer je mesure la
confiance que vous me témoignez j'en
suis profondément fier
fier mais désespérément seul avec les
autres candidats c'est toujours un
dialogue de sourds j'en ai un peu marre
des appels téléphoniques pour mme pons
pour une une biche hammam des gens qui a
fini par balles et je trouvais ça aurait
pu être un moment de rassemblement et de
rang rassemblement de toute la gauche
pour une candidature unique c'est une
candidature de plus ce marché derrière
christiane taubira c'est niet également
pour yannick jadot militants d'une
république de l'écologie des meilleurs
salaires aussi je veux immédiatement
augmenter le smic à 1400 euros nets et
le porter à 1500
du catena à chaque semaine sa nouvelle
polémique pour eric zemmour immigration
zéro rime avec délinquance 0 depuis les
hautes-alpes christiane taubira tente de
prendre de la hauteur monsieur zemmour
ne m'intéresse pas je ne suis pas
thérapeute une thérapie de famille elle
en aurait bien besoin psychodrame chez
les le pen marion maréchal blanche pour
eric zemmour sa tante marine s'agace et
pour cause à madrid pour la grand'messe
de l'extrême droite européenne
sa poignée de main avec le hongrois
viktor orban et franche le soutien de
certains de ses canons beaucoup moins
ceux qui veulent partir partent mais ils
partent maintenant c'est un manque total
de dignité de respect à l'égard de
l'ensemble de nos militants du respect
pour sa fille marine jean-marie en a
encore un peu en avril il la soutiendra
malgré une sympathie pour eric zemmour
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
vivement la prochaine
on nous la promet tait populaire et
c'est vrai qu'avec 390 mille votants la
primaire 1 qui s'est déroulé hier a tenu
toutes ses promesses et christiane
taubira l'a emporté devant l'eurodéputée
écologiste yannick jadot jean luc
mélenchon de la france insoumise
l'eurodéputé pierre larrouturou et la
maire de paris anne hidalgo victoire
nette pour l'ancienne garde des sceaux
mais pari raté pas d'union juste une
candidature de plus on en parle avec
roselyne febvre chef du service
politique de france 24 bonsoir roselyne
soir à chevannes quelle étrange scrutin
tout ça pour ça on a envie de dire oui
un étrange scrutin de a à z tout ça ne
tenait pas tellement la route on serait
un peu cru hier soir avec ses notes
qu'ils étaient donnés alors non pas dans
une primaire populaire mais à l'école
primaire avec des passable plus - donc
c'était un mélange entre l'école des
fans est un peu la mjc du coin donc
c'était un drôle de mélange en plus il
ya eu quand même lors de cette drôle de
campagne parce qu'ils aient pas vraiment
eu de campagne des visuels de promotion
bourré de fautes d'orthographe donc les
internautes s'en sont donné à coeur joie
nous ne pourrons pas laisser les
fonctionnaires se faire maltraités mal
traités et s au lieu de 1 er donc rien
n'allait en plus il y avait des
candidats qui avaient marqué leur
opposition à figurer dans cette campagne
c'est à dire yannick jadot anne hidalgo
et jean luc mélenchon et ils ont été
enrôlés de force et eu les malgré nous à
l'époque étaient enrôlés dans la
wehrmacht
mais bon évidemment tout ça n'a pas de
rapport mais là c'est elle et malgré eux
malgré eux ils étaient enrôlés dans
cette primaire dont il ne voulait pas et
d'un autre côté il y avait fabien
roussel fabien roussel qui lui ne
figurait pas et on se demande pourquoi
et aujourd'hui elle crie à l' unité elle
veut rassembler tout le monde alors que
dans le fond quand on regarde la
carrière d'anne hidalgo elle n'a été
qu'un missile anti parti socialiste
christiane desbiens christiane taubira
j'ai dit qu'hoarau pardonnez moi vous
avez raison directrice et bien je teste
en fait votre question très décousue
colère est grande bravo donc christiane
taubira en 94 elle est sur une liste de
bernard tapie aux européennes un pur
sous l'impulsion de françois mitterrand
qui voulait torpiller michel rocard donc
déjà divise le parti socialiste avec
tapis ensuite en 2002 bien évidemment lé
compte elle se présente contre lionel
jospin on l'accuse et bien de vouloir
torpiller lionel jospin et d'être en
quelque sorte l'article artisan de la
victoire de jean marie le pen au second
tour et puis elle part en pleine crise
du terrorisme lorsqu'elle est garde des
sceaux et qu'elle met à mal le président
de la république de l'époque dont qui
est françois hollande parce qu'elle part
du gouvernement en pleine crise sur la
la proposition de déchéance de sa
nationalité donc en terme de
rassemblement j'ai envie de dire il ya
mieux merci beaucoup rosini on vous
retrouve demain dans marty politique une
version longue de votre émission aux
côtés de frédéric rivière de rfi vous
recevez donc la meilleure de paris elle
est candidate à la présidentielle anne
hidalgo justement c'est ce qu'on appelle
un marronnier chez nous les journalistes
un sujet qu'on voit revenir
régulièrement des débats de la campagne
présidentielle en france la question de
la légalisation et de la vente de
consommation n'ont pas de marrons mais
de cannabis elle ressurgit encore une
fois dans les programmes absolument et
sujet d'importance surtout en france
raphaël c'est le pays d'europe qui
compte le plus de consommateurs de juin
mais aussi le pays où la répression est
l'une des plus sévères alors face à ce
constat que faire la question divise
l'écologiste yannick jadot par exemple
prônent une légalisation contrôlée du
cannabis à l'étranger la mesure fait
partie des promesses de la nouvelle
coalition au pouvoir en allemagne et le
pas déjà été franchie dans une vingtaine
d'états américains mais aussi au canada
premier pays du g7 à avoir légalisé le
cannabis y ont rejoint justement à
montréal notre correspondant françois
rihouet bonjour françois plus de trois
ans après l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
quel est le bilan
ouais c'était une des promesses de
justin trudeau en campagne pendant sa
première
en pagne de 2015 il souhaitait avec
cette légalisation au pouvoir je cite
permettre aux canadiens d'acheter un
produit secure approuvé par la santé
publique et de ne pas envoyer de
l'argent dans les poches des criminels
disait-il au moment où en fait cette
légalisation a commencé à l'octobre 2018
sur ce point de la criminalité du trafic
je vous propose d'écouter le
criminologue que j'ai interviewés david
décarie étude de l'université de
montréal lui et son équipe ont publié
plusieurs rapports de recherche sur
l'évolution du trafic illicite de
cannabis au canada depuis la
légalisation
souvent on vous parlait de 5 10 en
éliminer un marché loire une fois qu'une
licence de légaliser aujourd'hui on
parle environ que la moitié du marché
noir et au canada environ trois ans donc
on s'en est quand même très bien pour
éliminer une bonne partie du marché noir
d'ici l'horizon de 5 à 10 ans même si
des poches
période voilà et côté angers des enjeux
de santé publique c'est l'autre grand
enjeu de cette légalisation depuis trois
ans le canada qui se situait en 2010 est
juste avant la légalisation au même
niveau que la france en terme de
consommation déclaré des canadiens
adultes soit à peu près la moitié
d'entre eux qui disaient avoir consommé
au moins une fois du cannabis dans leur
vie et bien selon statistique canada il
y à une diminution de la consommation
chez les plus jeunes les moins de 17 ans
notamment et une augmentation légère
notable chez les plus de 25 ans pas
d'impact par ailleurs par exemple sur
les accidents de la route et la sécurité
routière toujours selon statistique
canada est toujours seulement trois ans
après cette légalisation merci beaucoup
françois pour toutes ces précisions en
direct de montréal ce sont deux
meilleures amies mais chez eux aussi
qu'on adore détester ici en france
comment les britanniques voit-il la
campagne présidentielle française et
philippe turn nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau bonsoir philippe vous allez nous
faire une revue de presse spéciale sur
le sujet je le rappelle vous êtes
chroniqueur internationale sur la chaîne
anglophone de france 24 l'élection
présidentielle en france
intéresse-t-elle nos amis britanniques
est toujours d'ailleurs on a du mal à le
croire peut-être en france mais les
onglets aime bien garder à nos oreilles
assez fixe sur les élections en france a
toujours été le cas et puis cette année
ce n'est pas une exception
y a pas une journée où il n'y a pas une
histoire dans la presse qui parle un peu
de ce qui se passe en france et une
fascination pour la vie française pour
les candidats pour l'élection
présidentielle est le premier candidat
qui fascine plus et magne mâcon lui même
est ce qui posera synchronisation ou pas
et quand est ce qui va l'annoncer on le
dit d'ailleurs dans les dépanneurs que
c'est probablement le l'union européenne
qui va utiliser le plus pour faire
valoir son statut d'homme d'état de de
faire en sorte que les gens l'apprécient
sur la scène internationale il savoir
regonfler ses sondages en france mais
aussi par seulement il maniait mâcon
mais sa femme brigitte mâcon les
premiers dame fascine toujours les
britanniques dans la presse et je me
souviens que carla bruni avait fasciné
la presse britannique lors de son
arrivée au pouvoir avec nicolas sarkozy
en 2007 est donc cette fois ci un big
mac ont aussi fait la une des journaux
cette fois ci dans un antique dans le
daily mail ou abri de mâcon dit aux
britanniques vraiment j'ai jamais été
très aimé par les français ni france et
français n'ont pas voulu de moi ils ont
vu mon mari emmanuel
aussi une autre femme qui était arrivée
face à emmanuel macron en 2010 est bien
connue des britanniques marine le pen ne
serait ce que par le patronyme opel il
ya eric zemmour et puis il ya tous ces
autres candidats alors oui comment c'est
exact et il ya en grande bretagne une
grosse interrogation une question que
tout mon spot mais comment est-ce que
c'est possible que l'extrême droite en
france et autant de succès parce que
chez les britanniques on a eu le ukip
mais l'ukip n'existe plus depuis le
dépendent de la grande bretagne de
l'union européenne il ya eu une toute
petite partie qui s'appelle le british
energy au portique et de l'extrême
droite mais qui n'a presque aucun
représentation grand beau temps on n'a
rien à voir avec la candidature de
jean-marie le pen ou de marine le pen et
encore moins un eczéma aujourd'hui donc
marine le pen est très connue des
britanniques comme son père jean marie
le pen avant elle est maintenant et
xénon commence à faire la une des
groupes comme the times en dix ans il
veut faire de la france la france
éternelle
ils essayent d'attirer les votons en
france mais les britanniques je pense
vraiment ils ont du mal à comprendre
d'où vient ce phénomène à l'extrême dans
pourquoi autant de soutiens pour
l'extrême droite en france alors qu'il
ya une droite traditionnelle qui est
représenté par valérie pécresse et la
gauche qu'est ce qui se passe pour la
gauche parce que la gauche en france
n'existe presque plus une personne à
gauche qui voit mon petit mieux connue
que les autres c'est anne hidalgo
pourquoi parce qu'à agnel ago est connu
comme le la personne qui reprit son pari
qui maire de paris comme sadik khan qui
est maire de la londe et donc les deux
se voient assez fréquemment ils sont
déjà vu un d'hidalgo commence à essayer
de parler anglais par toujours très bien
mais c'est de parler anglais avec sadie
cannes elle est connue mais on a du mal
à comprendre comment quelqu'un qui
représente le parti de françois
mitterrand les socialistes et françois
hollande peut faire aussi peu de
destination de vote à 3% pour les
élections présidentielles à venir donc
ce n'est pas terminé tous les jours et à
quelque chose et britanniques même si on
n'est plus dans l'union européenne sont
toujours aussi fasciné que la france de
la france qu'ils ont été toujours merci
beaucoup philippe pour ce point de vue
britannique sur la campagne longtemps du
national autre portrait des lecteurs
direction les hôtes france la picardie
et on part à la rencontre nathalie de la
chapelle infirmière qui a décidé de
quitter l'hôpital public qu'elle
qualifie de déshumaniser pour se mettre
à son compte elle s'est confiée à nos
reporters florence villeminot et julie
d'une glove sur les difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontés les
personnels soignants et le elle aura
exposé ses propositions pour faire
avancer la france regarde
[Musique]
je suis infirmière libérale depuis 2003
tu as été diplômé en 89 je travaille à
l'hôpital de creil jusqu'en l'an 2000
[Musique]
dans ma voiture j'ai ma référence à mon
petit gilet jaune je suis devenu gilet
jaune tout simplement parce que je vois
sur le terrain et pour moi et pour les
patients et pour ma famille comment se
passent les choses on a l'impression
d'avoir des gens qui font des lois qui
font des choses qu'ils votent des choses
pour eux et pas pour nous en bas
d'autant plus comme j'ai plus de 50 ans
m'a donné un petit peu les chiffres de
ce que j'aurai à la retraite c'est une
sacrée baffe quand même
[Musique]
bonjour j'aimerais bien savoir très bien
et au niveau du cou de l'autre côté
savoir la douleur c'est pareil ouais le
monde y passe parce que si je serai pas
le cas des métiers qui
ont pour eux que pas assez reconnus mais
on est reconnu par patient on les
connaît on sait leur vie donc c'est
comme si on était un petit peu de la
famille quelque part allez je vous
souhaite une bonne journée je vous dire
ce soir tu sois
[Musique]
l'hôpital et est déshumanisé on
déshumanise et les soins on déshumanise
et où c'était que du rendement
travailler sur un être humain sans être
humain c'est pas possible pour moi donc
j'ai démissionné je suis parti
j'adore mon métier
j'adore la façon dont j'arrive encore à
le faire
malheureusement je vois que par rapport
à l'évolution des choses mon métier se
transforme devient plus de la technique
prend une dérive qui ne me convient pas
pour l'avenir
[Musique]
si j'étais présidente je remettrai de
l'humain à l'hôpital et dans le libéral
j'arrêterai cette course à la
rentabilité et j'arrêterai ce lobbying
pharmaceutique et je créerai une
constituante pour redonner le pouvoir au
peuple afin qu'ils soient maîtres lui
même de son avenir
mais on en vient à présent un autre
archives de la semaine c'est un gros
clin d'oeil aux candidats de gauche qui
s'écharpent et rechignent à former un
front uni une archive de françois
mitterrand du 22 janvier 73 c'était lors
d'une conférence de presse commune des
trois dirigeants signataires du
programme commun pour un gouvernement de
la gauche aux côtés de françois
mitterrand qui représente donc le parti
socialiste georges marchais du parti
communiste et robert fabre du mouvement
des radicaux de gauche à quelques
semaines des législatives de mars 73
françois mitterrand parle de ses
rapports avec les communistes et de la
nécessaire union de la gauche donc
écouter
évident que nous sommes concurrents la
vie politique c'est comme cela devons
nous considérer que cette concurrence
doit nous amener à nous entre déchirer
il ya des moments historiques où l'on
pense que l'intérêt premier c'est la
défense des masques des travailleurs que
nous présentons en commun alors on s'est
entendu sur un contrat de cinq ans c'est
pas mal il semble même que beaucoup
trouvent c'est déjà trop et nous
appartiendra pour ce qui n'est pas un
programme commun non non non
il appartiendra lorsque nous arriverons
termes de ce contrat
d'examiner la situation qui en sera
menée et je vous le dis tout de suite le
parti socialiste puisque la question
était posée entend bien ne pas tourner
le dos à la stratégie politique admise
en 1972 quels que soient les résultats
des élections de 1973 voilà et à l'issue
des législatives de 1973 la majorité au
sein de l'assemblée nationale reste à
droite mais ton net recul grâce donc à
ce front uni de la gauche et voilà c'est
tout pour cette semaine raphaël le
prendre comme à lille n'aura pas survécu
à cet accord france au mitan serait lui
rend 81/100 programme commun c'est la
fin de france 2022 l'heure du choix
retrouver aussi sur notre site internet
france 24 points comme et sur les
réseaux sociaux rendez vous lundi
prochain m